they're saying that Americans bought
less wine last year it's the first drop
in a quarter of a century now I believe
this is because I quit drinking Kelly
Ripa reveals she quit drinking when Ryan
Seacrest came aboard alive with kelly
and ryan after Michael Strahan's 2016
exits the 49 year old talk-show host
says she bailed on booze on Mondays
episode while talking about a recent
drop in wine sales now I believe this is
because I quit drinking I caused this
dip
I have influenced the robbing people out
of drinking alcohol I'm not saying I've
driven people out I'm saying I stopped
buying wine and there's a toy it's your
visual purchase power Kelly didn't
reveal why or when she stopped drinking
but Ryan later seemed to imply that she
quit a while ago I started the show and
she quit drinking what does that tell
you I don't know
exactly is that good or bad it's amazing
Ryan joined the show in 2017 I just want
you to know that you are a privilege to
work with and I adore you after Michael
Strahan left the show to join Good
Morning America in 2016 it is your final
show yeah remember that that was awkward
AF you know I'm it's bittersweet you
excited I'm it's bittersweet of course
you get nervous like this it is I've
done this for four years so this is a
moment that I didn't anticipate being
here at least at this point but it's
here anyway back to Ryan I couldn't be
more excited to be here with you he sat
down with Kelly and Ryan just a few
months after he officially joined the
show and they opened up about their
immediate chemistry well you're the boss
so when did you know I mean we worked
together years ago years ago you filled
in for Regis yes and I we were just like
we said well that was a really fast hour
I mean I always say hosting our show is
the fastest hour on television but when
Ryan and I hosted together it seemed
like it I would say is it it's probably
a ten minute show it felt like ten
minutes and that's when you know it's a
really good pairing and you know she is
so quick and clever you can bring up
anything and she can run with it she has
a great line she's hysterical and so we
we opened the show and you know it's
it's 25 minutes into the show before we
even look up but I think and I get
excited I'm actually genuinely excited
to see her every morning I know in the
past sometimes you didn't say hi before
you go on the air I like to go say hi to
before we go on the air we don't talk
about too much but I still a little bit
well we've known each other a long time
I think that every day that I see her
she I will text her sometimes you know
how great she is and that I'm in awe of
what she can do and I don't know if it's
appreciated what a skill it is to do
this show and be a friend to strangers
every day on television and so she
impresses me
with her ability to do that and with
kindness every day I'm like I'm gonna
cry I'm about to cry it's true
I've worked with a lot of people and she
just has that magic crying you're crying
anyway you can count on me to bring you
all the latest kelly and ryan news so
make sure to keep it locked right here
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now
[Music]